[UPBEAT MUSIC PLAYING]
MARTIN AGUINIS: Hello, and
welcome to "Flutter Live."
I'm Martin Aguinis.
EMILY FORTUNA: And
I'm Emily Fortuna.
MARTIN AGUINIS: And we'll
be your host for all things
Flutter.
Wherever in the world
you're watching,
we are so happy that
you're joining us today
for this jam-packed
two-hour event.
EMILY FORTUNA: One
of my favorite things
about working on
Flutter is I get
to connect with people
from all over the world
to make their mobile
app ideas possible.
You may recognize me
from the presentations
I've given at Google
I/O, or on YouTube,
like the "Flutter Boring
Development Show."
MARTIN AGUINIS: You might
be familiar with my voice
on the "Introducing
Flutter" animation video,
or from some of my talks at
GDD China and Google Marketing
Live.
HILLEL COREN: Hi.
My name is Hillel
Coren I live in Israel,
and I'm the co-founder
of Invoice Ninja.
KELSEY: Hi.
I'm Kelsey from Austin, Texas.
I am a web developer.
FAISAL: I'm Faisal.
I'm a Flutter developer.
RONA KILMER: Hi.
My name's Rona Kilmer, and
I am in Denver, Colorado.
MARK THOMPSON: Hey, my
name is Mark Thompson.
I'm from Chicago, Illinois,
and I'm a software engineer
and an entrepreneur.
PAUL: My name is Paul
[? Sene, ?] from Tanzania.
I am the co-founder and Lead
Product Manager at [INAUDIBLE]..
With Flutter, it's been
really, really easy
to bring my ideas to life.
MARTIN AGUINIS: Here we are
inside the science museum IMAX,
and this screen is huge.
It's so big that you can
fit four double-decker buses
on top of each other.
Here we are in front
of Registration,
where all the on-site
attendees will be checking in.
But right after the
keynote, in this space
we have some really cool demos
and activations to show you.
All the way in the
back of the room,
we're going to have
a massive showcase
wall, with 99 phones that have
Flutter apps loaded on them.
[UPBEAT MUSIC PLAYING]
Nilay, you have
done an amazing job
at building up the Flutter
community all around the world.
I am seriously impressed.
NILAY YENER: Basically,
the community
attracted me about the Flutter,
and I just looked into that.
And it was a great team.
I'm so happy being in this team.
MARTIN AGUINIS: So
I'm standing here
with Eric Seidel, who is one
of the founders of Flutter.
Was there a moment where you
went, wow, this is legitimate?
This is really taking off.
ERIC SEIDEL: I think the biggest
moment for me was "Hamilton."
When we saw the
"Hamilton" app ship, when
we saw that team be
successful with Flutter,
helped me believe that,
yeah, anybody can use this.
MARTIN AGUINIS: (RAPPING)
The $10 founding father
without a father got a
lot farther by working
a lot harder, by
being a lot smarter,
by being a self-starter.
By 14, they placed him in
charge of a trading charter.
EMILY FORTUNA: (LAUGHING)
MARTIN AGUINIS: (LAUGHING)
SPEAKER 9: Yeah!
[WHISTLING]
EMILY FORTUNA: Flutter 1.0!
MARTIN AGUINIS:
Flutter 1.0 is here.
[UPBEAT MUSIC PLAYING]